primero pues qué significa para el
planeta que el 2022 ciudad el año más
seco registrado que se puede esperar
entonces para los años que vienen
bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación
hay algunos impactos fundamentalmente
sociales y ecológicos en los sociales
tenemos que entender que esto afecta a
la agricultura la disponibilidad del
agua potable el transporte nuestra
capacidad de generar energía entre
muchos otros aspectos de la vida
cotidiana claro sin duda la agricultura
es el campo más afectado por la sequía a
un nivel sectorial esto a su vez
contribuye al aumento de los precios de
los alimentos y en general podemos
concluir en que su consecuente
degradación ambiental limita el acceso a
la vida digna y evidentes problemas
ambientales las sequías amenazan los
ecosistemas esencialmente los
ecosistemas frágiles sagar afectando
gravemente a la biodiversidad y
aumentando el riesgo de incendios
forestales que es una problemática
global muy importante y particularmente
en la región
pues el señor fernando cortez que pueden
hacer entonces en este caso los
gobiernos también los ciudadanos las
empresas más allá de lo que ya se está
haciendo para mitigar ese impacto del
cambio climático a futuro
bueno en general yo creo que las
políticas públicas deben comenzar a ser
guiadas por la bioética y no por los
intereses
particulares y muchas veces corruptos
debemos en general mitigar el cambio
climático adaptarnos a lo que ya ha
cambiado y asumir con realismo las
pérdidas y daños
debemos ir repensando los usos del agua
fundamentalmente en la agricultura
promoviendo una transición basada en
eficiencia y asimismo debemos generar
políticas forestales de prevención de
incendios y regeneración ambiental por
último hay que considerar que las
respuestas actuales a la sequía tienden
a centrarse en medidas a corto plazo
como la conservación temporal del agua
sin embargo debemos integrar e
incorporar estrategias a largo plazo que
reduzcan la vulnerabilidad y aumenten la
resiliencia a las sequías en las
comunidades ciudades y países
bueno y que otras actividades aparte de
la agricultura se están viendo afectadas
por estas sequías en estos países
y bueno en general esto esto termina
afectando a las dinámicas económicas que
en las que se cimienta la vida que tiene
que ver con la producción de alimentos
que tienen que ver también con la
ganadería pero también se ven en otros
elementos como en la capacidad de
generar energía por ejemplo de energía
hidroeléctrica y aparte y es algo
fundamental y vemos una posible crisis
del agua por la limitación al acceso de
agua potable si bien los países más
afectados en este caso puede ser europa
china eeuu y en lugares de áfrica hay
que entender que latinoamérica también
es una región muy afectada no de acuerdo
con un estudio del observatorio global
de la sequía si comparamos los periodos
de la anterior década con los de ahora
vemos una gran crisis climática y por
eso que latinoamérica si bien ha
contribuido a la crisis climática es muy
afectada y vemos asumir la crisis
climática desde una perspectiva soporte